explain to me what was going on with
Abraham Lincoln fake fake beard thing
that was happening for that show because
I really legit thought because I hadn't
seen you online in a while and then you
pop back out and I'm like oh this guy's
just just saying like I don't know
what's happening here yeah it honest
this character I got big play day
um and I I was him in the r p video so I
was just like you know and I had to do a
TV show that day okay and I'm like you
know what and for the TV show I was big
play day my character that I my altar
it's kind of like my Alter Ego honestly
um and so for the TV show it's called
the south side so I had to uh be my
Alter Ego big play day and I had my
chops on I'm like you know what bro [__]
it I'm gonna do the show with them and I
didn't think it was I was just like yo
[__] it like I thought it was real for
sure creative yeah that's crazy a [__]
look like Kareem Abdul-Jabbar is like
Jesus he's going straight 70s porn mode
on these mothers for real straight up
baby nights out here absolutely yeah
did you say BBC Jesus Christ you said it
you said it repeated it